it's time for the biennale again in
Venice when contemporary art is shown
against a historic backdrop the opening
days are a special time for
international artists to meet and greet
German painter guy abaza 'let's is among
those in town his works are on display
but he says he's come because the venue
with its hustle and bustle surrounding
the art are well worth it leave a jet so
wicked so why was sort of a recluse once
or twice a year I venture out into the
art world then I see that everyone's
still there just older I talk about and
some are doing better some others worse
it's just the same old same old but it's
actually a very lustrous first you
encounter and that's fun what is much
especially in Venice it's great fun
finding in de need is much the school
search bus
his works are hanging in the gallery in
the Arsenal ax which was a former
shipyard 8 larger-than-life
self-portraits can be seen in an
eight-sided space
the fitness wonder by fender I think
it's wonderful this design with the open
octagon is very good for these spaces
Zack would fit easily you couldn't do
better except maybe put them 50
centimeters higher but that won't work
because of the lining tracks but I'm
still really pleased keep it up through
the self portraits are Basel it's as
latest works he finished the last one
just before the Biennale
this modèle this in photo of us minor
fall for me Liam laughed at it's based
on a photograph that my wife took of me
and I have the photo in my hands the
left-hand side doesn't look so great
because I'm not so young anymore I tried
to remedy this by putting pretty colors
on a dark background and painting as
flat as I could so that there's not the
three-dimensionality in the body none of
the surrounding space either all kind of
warm least cut them home more than half
of the nearly 140 artists participating
are making their be Anala debut this
year Nigerian curator Oh qui and ways or
made a special effort to give a platform
to artists who are frequently
underrepresented in the Western
dominated art world leonardo-san us for
the noi common kunstler Libyan Allah is
actually for up-and-coming young artists
the newly discovered ones or D cup as
asses off the Lisa TV show I've had a
look at the list to find out if I'm the
oldest of the 140 artists overstated is
to bid and I am at least the oldest
painter the big difference but his eyen
isn't firma there's a filmmaker banner
hat so he's a bit older and that's it or
that made a big impression huh mark was
our dog off leash
most of the 89 national pavilions are
located in a park the JD knee each
country chooses independent of the
curator which artists will represent it
in 1980 gyo basel it's designed the
german pavilion together with unzen
keifa another german artist he showed
his first wood sculpture back then it
caused an uproar because some took it to
be a depiction of Hitler the SWA azubu
him end public resistance and the press
opposition even more were so vehement
but I really thought it was the end for
me if it meant vida antes de zaak
receive it a and the aggression shown
towards my work was unbearable diba
Thomas but I managed who not likely away
helps for kofta but this vehement
opposition you don't see that today
anymore even after the artists like II
abaza let's head home their works can
still be seen in Venice up until the end
of november organizers say they expect
more than half a million people to visit
the bein allah